bonjour verra ravi de vous avoir dans la
matinale de rtl france quelle est la
situation à moscou actuellement
bonjour magali la cour des
contaminations aux copies de 19 et
tendance à les autorités de moscou même
si enquête de l'association n'envisage
pourtant pas de confinement
le maire de la capitale sergueï
sobianine estime que pour l'instant la
ville n'en a pas besoin
je vous propose d'écouter
malheureusement la situation reste
compliquée jour après jour nous
assistons à une nouvelle augmentation du
nombre des cas d'infection par le
comique 19 le nombre des lits d'hôpitaux
déployés pour les personnes infectées
par le comique 19 s'accroît aujourd'hui
il y en a environ 10000 dans les jours à
venir nous ouvrirons plusieurs hôpitaux
supplémentaires qui seront utilisés dans
le cadre de la lutte contre le colis de
19 pourtant nous n'envisageons pas
d'imposer aucun confinement estimons
qu'à ce stade la nounou s'en passeront
l'adjointe au maire de moscou anastacia
kova a compté regretté le non respect
des gestes-barrières par les moscovites
ainsi que le faible nombre des personnes
vaccinées malgré la disponibilité du
romed écouté depuis sept semaines
nous constatons une augmentation des cas
de malades atteints par locaux vides 19
en vue d'assurer l'assistance médicale
nécessaire à chaque moscovite
nous augmentons le nombre des lits de
nos établissements médicaux qui traite
du coronavirus à ce jour douze mille
cinq cents lits sont utilisées dans la
lutte contre les coronavirus les
épidémiologistes avoir un lien entre
l'augmentation des cas où l'on résumé d
mesure j'allais vivre le maire a déjà
déclaré plus tôt aujourd'hui voiture
aucune mesure de restriction voire le
confinement ne sera introduit dans ces
conditions la supporter la charge
principale incombe au personnel médical
monsieur dont je dis maintenant s il
ressemble beaucoup à ce que je disais et
un impôt mais la situation est
radicalement différente ou 11 ans cette
année et chacun de nous a une
opportunité de protéger son nez ses
proches de cette terrible maladie
quand je mange chacun peut se faire
vacciner avec le vaccin degas son
efficacité est fictive moscou possède un
large réseau de transit et de
vaccination dans la fable de satisfaire
chaque personne qui en a envie à tout le
moins il suffit de venir et de se faire
vacciner
pasciuto le couple étiez 6-3 plus de dix
mille nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont
été détectés en russie ce 24 heures dont
plus de 4000 à moscou beaucoup vérins
pour ce point sur la situation sanitaire
en direct de moscou ce matin